I was talking to John hin last night
actually I knew he had gone to the big
Michigan game you're a big Michigan guy
you said they stormed the field and it
was scary this is the ultimate rivalry
in sports Michigan Ohio State goes back
forever schools hate each other both
undefeated we were on the field and
Michigan won and there's 110,000 people
in this Stadium it's the largest stadium
in the country and we ran out and we're
all excited and all a sudden you turn
and everyone is and it was terrifying
you're there because you you're you know
you're cheering and then you can't move
you can't get off the field students all
drinking since 6:00 in the morning it's
a noon start they're coming on you're
trying to get off it was like a concert
where you read about people getting
trampled it was terrifying I don't get
the whole like stampeding I see people
starting to run onto a field I go this
looks like danger I'm I'm going the
opposite way once everybody rushes onto
the field there's nothing thing to do
there's nowhere to go yeah what do you
do again we were on the field for the
game what do you mean you were on the
field for the game you were playing in
the game I they didn't you know they
didn't call they didn't call my number I
was waiting no we were standing on the
sideline but then I really it clicked in
my head wait a minute we can't get out
if we didn't want to storm the field
like we were going in the wrong
direction because 100,000 were coming
this way so we were going on the field
regardless and then in the middle of the
field that's where the players and the
coaches are and everybody wants to you
know say great job this and that and
then they clear out a tunnel so the
players and can get off but you can't go
through that tunnel so Robin's right
you're standing there you're cheering
you're clapping everyone loves each
other and like now what do we do and
they're making a stadium announcement uh
could you please leave the field it's
you know it's time we're thrilled that
we won and nobody's listen you got a
bunch of drunk students coming out there
nobody's listening everybody wants to
get on the field and jump and party and
so it was great and then it was
terrifying